(audience cheering)
Our next guest is a renowned
drummer and one of the most talented
and beloved musicians in the world
and she just released the new music video
for the salsa version of her original song "Bailar."
Please welcome the queen of percussion,
the one and only Sheila E.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat intro music)
Hi!
Oh my God, and your eye liner!
Go and say what?
Oh my God, I love you so much!
(audience cheering)
(Sheila E laughing)
Okay.
I am so excited, you just broke a record.
You and your dad, Pete Escovedo,
for being the first father, daughter to win this award.
Tell us about it?
Yeah, we--
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
We were honored to receive the Lifetime Achievement Award
from the Latin Grammy's and there's never been a father
and daughter to ever receive that.
I know, cry!
I know, I cried like a baby for like 20 minutes.
I couldn't get it together.
I was so happy for him because to be acknowledged
by our peers in, he's just stuck to his music
this whole time when people kept saying
it would never work, you know?
So I'm happy for him.
(audience cheering)
I'm so happy
that you could break a record with your father.
Who by the way, I feel like we have a lot in common
'cause did you grow up in nightclubs?
Yes I did. (laughing)
Me too!
I did.
My dad, early on my mom had a job
and my dad being a musician,
he went to rehearsals and he said I was in one little basket
and he would put me on the counter at the club
and then the, a bartender or the waitress would watch me.
I'm like, "You left me with people?"
Like, but anyway he did what he had to do.
So I grew up in the bars like that.
Those were good times.
Yes, they were, it was a lot of fun.
It really was.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
I watched your talk show.
Thank you for coming here.
Ah, thank you.
But you have a talk show on YouTube
and really amazing guests.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, yeah.
Fred Armisen, and Misty Copeland.
I mean, I was watching a few episodes, it's amazing.
Thank you, yeah, I had Ringo.
I just called my--
Ringo Starr?
I know, yeah.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
You know, I admired you so much growing up.
I loved watching you solo.
I loved watching you with Prince.
I loved watching you be a woman.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
There was nobody like you,
you certainly carved out, you know,
something all your own and owned it.
Yes, yes.
I mean, watching my dad play every single day in the house,
he played to vinyl to LP, the records
and brought music in the house.
And then his friends happened to be incredible musicians.
And we lived growing up in the Bay Area
in Oakland, San Francisco,
it's just like everyone was from there.
Carlos Santana, Grateful Dead,
these people were coming to our house
and we would be able to jam with them
and so I watched my dad play,
even though I was training to be in the Olympics.
I was a track star.
And then I played this one gig with my dad at 15,
and I had just realized, "Wait, I think, wait a minute,
this is what I'm supposed to do.", you know?
I had no idea how incredible it was to play with my dad
at 15 years old.
And that show, after we were done,
I told my dad, "Daddy, daddy, this is what I want to do,
I want to be a musician."
He's like, "No, no, no, are you kidding me?"
And I was like, "no!".
But he knew it.
And then two weeks later we went out on tour
and I never looked back.
That was it the beginning, two weeks later.
It's like you had something bursting inside of you.
Yeah.
And then it was unleashed.
And what was life with Prince like?
There's one story I really like
about how you fooled him once.
So, he had this party and he said,
"It's going to be a costume party.
So, everyone's coming to the party
and whoever wins", I think it was like $5,000?
I'm like, "Oh, I'm getting that money.", right?
So I dressed up, I had my security guard,
he's like 6'9".
(Drew gasps)
And I said, "You know what?
The only way for us to win this is
I'm going to have to put some costume stuff on, like,
I'm going to dress up like a guy."
So I, it wasn't a guy really.
I was a pimp and he was my ho, right?
That's what I did.
And so I had my makeup artist go
and I got real hair and we glued it
and I asked for a mustache
and I put chest hair and I dress like a dude for real,
like, and I said, I was a pimp, I had a cane.
They brought me a suit, a tie and it was incredible.
So we walked around.
So, he walked by me four times.
He did not know it was me.
And then finally, I had to walk up to him.
I said, "Prince" and he just looked at me, he goes,
and he just fell, he was literally laying on the floor
on his back laughing.
And I got that money. (bangs table)
(Drew and audience cheering)
(upbeat theme music)